And somehow
tonight's town hall with the former
president played with
some of New Hampshire's
Republican and undeclared voters
who were in the audience,
one of them seniors, Gary
Tuchman, who's with a group of them now.
Gary,
Anderson, eight people were with
they were in the audience.
What they also have in common is
none of them have voted in the past
for either Joe Biden or Hillary Clinton.
Six of them voted for Donald Trump.
Of the past.
One didn't
vote in the past two elections.
One was too young to vote.
But that's what they have in common.
And most of them are Trump supporters.
What I want to ask you, first of all, is
do you think show of hands?
Anybody think Donald Trump
looks better after this townhall?
And if you think it looks worse
and if you think the same thing about him
as you did when you walked in.
So all of you feel that way.
First thing
I want to ask you
about Donald Trump,
we have to be blunt about
it is not a truth teller.
That's where he's always been
when he was a businessman.
He's been a politician.
He has lied about the 20, 20 election
stuff, ballot boxes.
That's all made up.
He's lost dozens of court cases.
Does it bother you
that he keeps talking about 20, 20
and not 20, 24?
I'll ask you first.
This is Jonathan Leslie.
He's 40 Republican,
voted for Trump twice.
How do you feel about those lies?
So I feel like part of it's
also the media narrative.
As you guys
asked him
the first question at the town
hall about the 2020 election
rather than current stuff.
So don't you think he could say it's time
for me to start talking about 20, 24,
not lies that aren't true?
Couldn't the media ask him a question
about 20, 24?
Well, there were questions,
but you're right,
that was the first thing.
But that's something
that was on our mind.
And that's why I was asked first
Mike McLaughlin is 21.
He is undeclared,
which is what you do in New Hampshire
if you want to be independent.
T voted for Trump in 2020.
Mike same thing to you.
What do you feel about Trump
continuing to talk about those mistruths
from 2020?
Personally, I'm getting tired
of hearing about it.
I'm very much more so interested
in the problems that we face now.
And I would prefer to hear him
discuss the present issues more so than
going to the past.
65 year old Stephen
Farnsworth, Republican
voted for Trump twice.
Your opinion about that?
Well, I think that he is committed to it.
That's what he feels.
That's what he thinks.
What is this about that?
Or do you think he just keeps saying it
to try to will it
for people like you to believe?
I think he actually thinks that you do.
Now, he may
even though he keeps losing in the courts
over and over again,
that he does say what's on his mind.
Okay. Do you? Do you think so?
I thought it was that
it was a rigged election in your book
or the next person or list.
64 year old.
And you don't mind me
saying your age, Cindy, on into you?
I don't know. Okay.
We were joking about for at least
one more month.
Yeah, she's a Republican.
She didn't vote the past
two presidential elections.
How come you didn't vote? A and B.
What do you feel about
the continuation of these lies?
About 20. 20.
You know,
I don't know what's a lie anymore,
but I think there needs
to be a new narrative
and what's the new narrative?
Current current situations that are,
you know, involving all of us.
Current situations.
But when you say you don't know
what's a lie, a lie is a lie.
I mean, all these courts have said
there isn't one of the stuff.
Ballot things
he's talking about was in Fulton
County, Georgia.
No stuff ballots.
I was there.
I was watching it with my own eyes.
I mean, none of it's true.
And I think a lot of people think
he tries to. Will it to be true.
Would you agree with that?
Yes. Okay.
And that corner right there,
that's an all
the court is 18
first election
coming up is currently undeclared
but leaning Republican.
What do you feel about him
still talking about 2020 in these things.
I don't think anybody wants to hear
about 20, 20 at this point.
Everybody wants to hear about 20,
20 for the future
and what comes after that.
And he did not talk
enough about that tonight.
Listen Malloy, this is 37.
She's a registered Republican,
voted for Trump twice.
Your feeling about this?
I think it's time to move on
from the election.
The 20, 20 election is Phibbs a venue.
I think he truly believes it.
You do too, I think.
Yeah, I think that's
what he truly believes.
I know.
I think a lot of his supporters
believe it.
Not all of them,
but there are a lot of people
who do believe it.
And he tries to,
you know, go along with that.
And I would agree
that he rules it to be true.
I me ask.
22 year
old Cooper Walsh who is also undeclared
but voted for Trump at 2020.
Do you think Trump believes it?
I definitely do think he believes it
and he's very passionate about it.
Or else he probably wouldn't
still be talking about it.
But I think that it's time
for him to move on.
He needs to talk about
what he's going to accomplish in 20, 24.
And I also think the media
should focus
on the huge segment on the 2020 issue
We already know what he thinks about it
and think we should be talking
about one of the other issues
that the questions had in the audience.
But would it be helpful.
Karen Olsen who's 56
she's undeclared
not registered Republican or Democrat
but voted for Trump twice.
What have you got if you would just say
I'm ready to move on. 20, 24.
I'm going to stop lying.
I'm going to be honest about it
and move on.
Wouldn't that be helpful then?
The news media wouldn't ask him about it
if he would acknowledge it.
I'd like him to move on.
I would like him to
stop talking about it,
but it is his opinion.
So you have to attach that caveat.
You lie all the time.
It just keeps it going.
So it's his opinion
and he has a right to have it.
All right.
Just yesterday, a nine member jury found
Donald Trump liable for sexual abuse
and is continuing to mock Jean Carroll,
this woman who was sexually abused,
according to the jury,
He also says that that was rigged.
You know, this
not only is a jury of his peers,
he's a New Yorker.
He may live in Mar-A-Lago
right now, the mansion in Palm
Beach, Florida,
but he was born and raised in Queens,
New York.
Wanted to make it big
with his father in Manhattan did.
He's a New Yorker.
This was truly a jury of his peers.
How do you make it feel
that he's still making fun of this woman
and ask the women that question
It's uncomfortable.
It's definitely uncomfortable.
And I just don't know
what to think anymore.
How do you feel about that?
It makes me uncomfortable.
I haven't followed it too closely.
So I really I agreed.
I don't feel like I have a
strong opinion.
And how do you feel?
I mean, this this was a jury.
These jurors weren't told.
You have to say this
is this is our system
of the United States of America.
This is an amazing system.
It's not a perfect system,
but it is an amazing system,
particularly compared
to lots of other countries.
They agreed on this.
And here he is at this town hall today.
I've never met her before
and just been making fun of her.
How does that make you feel as a woman?
I didn't really care.
Why don't you care?
I don't know enough about the case.
Women
can be victims of abuse.
Women can also make up stories.
I mean, we see it all the time,
so I don't know.
All of these situations
where people coming out
20, 30 years later, I don't listen to it.
One more question for Mike Pence.
He said regarding January 6th
that he doesn't think
Pence was in danger.
He doesn't feel
the need to apologize to him.
Does that offend any of you
that he's not willing to tell Mike Pence,
I'm sorry, you could have been hanged.
Anyone offended by that?
Sure.
You are.
In the final question,
Any of you ready to say
you're ready to vote for Donald Trump
at 20, 24?
I am.
You are one person.
The rest of you
not ready to say that yet.
Thank you all for joining us.
We very much appreciate your time
in this very important political
state of New Hampshire.